so we're going to try to get rid of this
dis rotational weakness in our body
posture right title encodes is actually
that it's not just a way of reconciling
dis grip is that you can hold your four
corners on a rotational basis and so
there were 20 pushes me here to see how
to start eternity I didn't like that so
yes I'm going to have my brown top but
I'm not gonna let him turn me right or
disconnect my hip you see that I'm just
here like this okay and so he's pushing
and I'm just sending it in to the ground
and at the same time I'm trying to have
no different sensation in this shoulder
and an additional other than initiative
and
anywhere else in my life and we get the
other one so some of you I will have to
like lock out just don't do the bracing
angle try to find the ground so my back
leg is mid foot weighted that means my
knee is going to be bent on the back leg
okay so those that can you pass that
then what you're going to try to do
don't let me contains you if you're
going to try to relax everything without
losing that structure you relaxing more
and more more and more this constantly
release me more this is not it you see
he's squeezing my tendons so that's not
the structure I still have my hand but
everything he can do the same thing so
he should be training the same way so
I'm here and if I can get there and what
I'm going to do you slowly start to
release what happens is he feels the
tension go away and then he will be
affected by that and he stops pushing
and now I'm not training so you have to
watch that okay so I get him to push
because I'm pushing but as soon as he
feels me start to release then he steals
mom don't do that he has to keep pushing
the same way and I just keep release
okay let's try this okay so I'm now
going to take that posture and move with
it with Tsuyoshi so I'm not going like
this and then dropping cuz he's doing
his job you won't get back now so get
the positive angle and then you just
move in the same skill levels as as
we're getting it I'm just going to be
relaxed
just relax I need a little external
tension to go ahead and do it what you
don't want to do is this I don't want
I'm working on the rotational integrity
so I'm here
then we'll do the side and he keeps
pushing so take your push off that's not
it
he has to keep the tension so that I am
training myself he's fishing and I do
the step and now I'm gonna fold my arm
and and he's gonna go to the elbow and
now how you do everything is okay so
here go and I tried to relax and I know
I've Genesee I did it again I got him to
relax okay
and so that's telling me I'm doing what
I need to do but you can't do that okay
so I just do the drill boom then here
okay let's try that so he here what I'd
like to see of course those that need
this integrity but the other ones you
need to try to relax his it's all of
this go okay if you want to try to relax
oh I'm very you can't you can't let me
suffer you in so I'm very relaxed very
relaxed
here I'm very good hey relax relax
okay okay so obviously we're putting
pressure on the corner if if you look at
this my arm my upper arm is going to be
in the same position when I bend my
elbow you see that you see that I would
go back and my shoulder is in the same
position so when I go to the elbow it
should feel as if my hand is there okay
and so when I go to the shoulder it
should feel like my hand is there do you
understand what we're what we're
observing right and the swishing and
swaying is that you learnt didn't use
this part using the part we're taking
away you get that so you have to maybe
use your imagination so I'm keeping my
elbow in the same place well shoulder in
the same place
[Music]
hey hey so watch your bracelet angle to
see how you're doing that
that's a race man you know you can do it
like go ahead he's pushing it right I'm
still doing the same thing I still doing
the same thing still doing the same
thing still doing the same still doing
the same thing I'm locking in place okay
so same thing goes for this side watch
that this side doesn't take your mind
and this side has got no energy in it do
you understand it should be boys if
there's a hand over here right and I'm
doing this ain't
okay as opposed to this kind of stuff do
you see it's like someone it looks like
someone shot a tranquilizer darts okay
come on
[Music]
again don't you can't let me pull you
okay
all right it relax Joe relax relax
yeah nice gonna come in with you now and
I go to here and we want to make sure
that side is a lot and then go so the
feeling right is the same the feeling is
the same boom boom boom boom
you know I don't want to see you go this
size is dead it's nice dead this size is
dead and then you see that's not the
same yeah just be calm and transfer what
you're feeling on one side to the other
side so just like we're going to think
about it differently my elbow is already
my shoulders already doing anything so
when I take away the wrist of the floor
nothing changes nothing changes do you
understand okay so same thing here it
looks like I need him to touch me and
then then I can go I don't when we come
back here you see not touching my hands
it's not that mass touching me yes it's
no different than him grabbing me I'm
pushing through it's no different for
contact here and I'm pushing through you
you understand it's the same matter
touch you mother okay same thing here
when I'm stepping in it's not a
displacement okay so when he comes in
right I'll bring them in boom and don't
have to go into
it's still the same matter touching
matter of energy touching energy so I'm
going to try to write I doesn't matter
ergo it doesn't matter or a ball it
doesn't matter
boom I don't know I'm gonna bring him
allow him to come into the projection
point understand versus me pushing him
away okay so here I am doing I don't
know what you want to call it a positive
projection dry and then here I'm going
to do passes okay let's try